peu
c'est pas les adieux c'est un verrou
venir un horaire donc c'est comment
dirais-je une situation même notre
privilégiées je peux prendre l'exemple
de monsieur du style est pas là mais
enfin on n'en voudra pas que je crois
quitté la maison au bout de 17 ans et
qui est revenue première fois d'abord
comment je crois un administrateur
intérimaire et qui est revenue
maintenant comme administrateur et comme
acteur régulier
moi je peux vous promettre que je
reviendrai comme acteur qui concerne
l'administration je ne promets rien ne
suis pas sûr mais a sûrement c'est pas
une soirée comme une honte quand même
j'ai rarement vu aussi
mais ses responsables parce que tout
d'un coup je voulais partir pas en douce
j'ai rien à cacher mais enfin je voulais
partir doucement comme on l'a fait pour
le fil à la patte comme ça c'est fait et
puis tout d'un coup ça a pris fallait
déclarations n'ont pas de notre faute je
dirais si vous avez été pendant des
années un des numéros un des français
s'est alors j'ai reçu des fleurs des
télégrammes pour à une première en fait
une dernière vous comprenez que tout est
à remettre mais enfin je suis bien
content c'est vrai pas que ce soit fini
non mais ça va ça peut se changer sa
pause pour manger puis toute façon vous
partez pas pour rien je n'ai rien des
projets je partais pour rien les projets
sont venus se greffe est prêt je partais
parce que vous avez tant choisir offert
ce que j'ai 25 ans je fais plus mais
enfin j'ai fait c'est tout c'est une
chose humain ça fait 25 ans qu'il est
ici 25 ans qu'il a une activité
débordante 25 ans qu'il a eu des des
succès des triomphes qui l'a illustré la
maison de molière qu'il a joué au
molière qu'il a joué tous les grands
auteurs classiques modernes c'est pas
cause d'un soir comme ça que l'on se
sépare d'un acteur comme lui c'est pas
possible
et puis est-ce qu'on peut le dire mais
c'est vous qui allez le mettre en scène
pour cent oui c'est vrai il s'en va il
va jouer ou à la rentrée au théâtre des
bouffes parisiens une pièce d'yves
janiak et je vais le retrouver on va
travailler en ce sens je vais mettre en
scène la pièce
alors on ne se qui parle c'est une
grosse perte pour la comédie france
c'est une grosse perte pour la comédie
française c'est incontestable mais
jusqu'à présent la comédie française a
su réparer ses pertes au fil des années
et à des comédiens importants qui sont
partis ont succédé des comédiens comme
robert hirsch qui sont absolument unique
là ce soir la société ne s'écroule pas
ceci la maison de molière est la
croissance je compte paquet qu'elle
s'écroule et très solide
[Musique]